et on en parle avec Igor de la Noé
directeur adjoint de l'Observatoire
franco-russe bonjour bonjour d'abord un
mot vous vous comprenez vous ce qui a
cherché à faire et gagner Prigogine
évitez comme il le dit aujourd'hui de
voir son groupe de mercenaires absorbé
par l'armée au premier juillet
oui effectivement il y avait une comment
dirais-je un étau qui se resserrer sur
Wagner depuis quelques jours puisque il
y a environ une dizaine de jours la la
le président du comité de la défense de
la Douma a annoncé qu'un projet de loi
serait prochainement soumis en vue de
réglementer l'activité des sociétés
militaires privées et quelques jours
plus tard le mise de la défense c'est
agrishwigo annoncé que au premier
juillet toutes les formations armées
opérants en Ukraine devait être
obligatoirement sous contrat avec le
ministère de la Défense et quelques
jours plus tard le président Poutine
s'exprime lors de la session plénière du
forum Saint-Pétersbourg expliqué qu'il
fallait réglementer l'activité des
sociétés militaires privées donc si vous
voulez cette séquence
certainement qu'on devient monsieur le
prix d'origine à conclure qu'il était
deux au mur et qu'il devait jouer son va
tout s'il voulait conserver la maîtrise
de sa société
Wagner maintenant est-ce que c'est à
travers cette folle équipée sauvage sur
Moscou qui pouvait le faire j'en suis
pas certain en tout cas il y a peu de
chances qu'il vous souhaitez prendre le
pouvoir des règles dit lui-même samedi
puisque ce n'est pas avec une centaine
de véhicules et 1000 ou 2000 hommes
qu'on fait monter sur Moscou qu'on prend
le pouvoir ça risquait pas d'arriver
donc c'était un cours de un tour de
force monsieur Prigogine était en
situation un peu désespéré un
désespérais d'autres et en quelque sorte
et donc il a tenté ce coup de force
trigogine qui estime que l'avancée
spectaculaire de Wagner sur cette 180 km
de territoire russe et en direction de
Moscou révèle de graves problèmes de
sécurité pourquoi l'aviation russe n'est
pas intervenue pour neutraliser le
convoi de Wagner on a vu ni mix ouille
absolument oui il y a eu des accrochages
avec des hélicoptères au niveau de vos
rosiers donc en milieu de la journée de
samedi puisque officiellement il y a un
bilan qui fait tes tâches je crois d'une
demi douzaine d'hélicoptères dont deux
hélicoptères de combat détruits et un
avion mais on n'a pas vu d'avion d'appui
au sol de sous roi 25 de son Roy 24
enfin des choses qu'on peut voir en
revanche à l'oeuvre en Ukraine pourquoi
moi je pense que pendant cette journée
de samedi il y avait évidemment celui à
posteriori un des négociations qui
étaient engagées en coulisse afin de
trouver une issue d'un manque
catastrophe catastrophique possible à
cette à cette crise et un bombardement
de la colonne avec de l'aviation
aurait probablement provoqué la rupture
de ces négociations en tout cas il y
avait un risque qui est une rupture de
négociation et ensuite un saut vers
l'inconnu avec pourquoi pas des combats
dans Rostov je rappelle que quand même
que la guerre nationale tchétchène était
aux portes de Rostov et là on peut être
dans une spirale incontrôlable avec à la
clé potentiellement le scénario de 1917
qui était évoqué par Vladimir Poutine en
tout cas c'était le grand saut pour
probablement vers l'inconnu donc je
pense que ce qu'on a vu dans la région
avec ses hélicoptères qui étaient là qui
ont été détruits d'ailleurs pour une
partie d'entre eux ces hélicoptères est
plutôt vocation à faire de
l'intimidation de la dissuasion des tirs
de sommation mais à mon avis n'était pas
là pour détruire cette cette colonne qui
s'est arrêtée en fin d'après-midi une
fois qu'un compromis a été trouvé entre
les parties au conflits plus
généralement est-ce qu'il y a un
problème logistique aujourd'hui avec
l'aviation russe comment expliquer cette
discrétion de l'aviation sur le fond
ukrainien alors on nous explique
évidemment que sont les défenses
anti-aériennes ukrainiennes qui qui
dissuadent tout incursion dans dans
l'espace ukrainien mais tout de même
est-ce qu'il y a pas des questions à se
poser
les questions on se les pose depuis le
22 24 février 2022 mais ils ont sur la
séquence récente qui nous intéresse un
peu plus disons depuis le déclenchement
de la contre-offensive ukrainienne au
début du mois de juin on a vu sur la
ligne de front une aviation russe quand
même beaucoup plus présente les
Ukrainiens d'ailleurs se plaignent de
l'activité de cet aviation russe et pour
la première fois depuis le début du
conflit on dit que la Russie a la
maîtrise de l'espace aérien de manière
très localisée sur la zone vraiment
d'affrontement là où est la bâti ces
lignes de défense et ses fortifications
très très résistante visiblement et si
elle tient enfin en tout cas si jamais
la contre-offensive craignait pour
l'instant ne semble pas avoir donné les
résultats escomptés c'est à la fois à
cause du travail de l'artillerie russe
mais aussi avec l'aviation la pluie de
l'aviation en russe qui vient étrier les
les troupes ukrainiennes donc on est un
petit peu sur depuis ces trois semaines
sur un changement de mode j'allais dire
par rapport à l'emploi de tes aviation
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu depuis un an
et demi maintenant
trigogie n'a pas révélé un où il se
trouve alors que le Kremlin assure qu'il
partira pour la Biélorussie sont
toutefois dire con que peut-il espérer
il glaner d'après vous quel rôle peut-il
jouer là-bas
alors sur là où se trouve trico jigne
plusieurs rumeurs dans la journée
d'abord on a prétendu qui se trouvait
dans la région de Google puis il aurait
été aperçu en fin de journée à mince en
tout cas il y a des rumeurs assez
persistantes sur les réseaux sociaux qui
font état de sa présence à mince bon le
fait qu'on sait pas vraiment où il se
trouve il se fait peut-être un petit peu
plus discret en dépit du message qu'il a
qui l'a communiqué moi je pense que
cette évidemment délocalisation de
précogine en Biélorussie est une des
conditions manifestement du compromis
qui a été trouvé samedi on va un petit
peu le mettre au vert en Biélorussie
pour quelques temps moi je n'exclus pas
qu'en fait la société Wagner soit
purement et simplement relocalisé en
Biélorussie autrement dit que le
problème que poser Wagner à nos
autorités russes soient tout simplement
déplacées en Biélorussie c'est une
solution qui peut être provisoire mais
qui après tout pourquoi pas ne pourrait
durable ce qui permettrait à Monsieur
Prigogine de poursuivre ses activités
depuis la Biélorussie cas échéant d'être
déployés en Ukraine si les choses
venaient à mal tourner pour l'armée
russe et surtout
ce qui à mon avis est le plus important
pour pour le Kremlin et bien qu'il
puisse poursuivre ses activités au
Moyen-Orient et en Afrique d'ailleurs
monsieur l'adrop a précisé cet
après-midi que les activités de Wagner
que ça soit depuis Bangui ou depuis
Bamako n'était aucune mort remise en
question et que tout se poursuivait
j'allais dire comme d'habitude merci
gore de la Noé d'avoir été avec nous
dans Paris direct